Pensez à quelqu'un que vous avez croisé aujourd'hui :
votre chéri(e), un ami, une collègue, un voisin; peu importe.
Qu'est-ce qui vous prouve que cette personne
à laquelle vous pensez possède une conscience ?
Alors bien sûr les êtres humains qu'on croise
tous les jours on l'air conscients,
ils sont éveillés, ils s'expriment,
ils réagissent quand on leur parle,
mais ce qu'on appelle la conscience
c'est un peu plus que ça.
Du matin au soir, dans nos têtes, se joue un film intérieur,
on a des pensées, des sensations,
des émotions, on ressent des choses,
on vit ce qu'on appelle une expérience subjective.
Et qu'est-ce qui me prouve que les gens que je croise
tous les jours eux aussi vivent ça à l'intérieur ?
La conscience a beau être le phénomène le plus immédiat
auquel on soit exposé quotidiennement,
il n'y a pas de consensus clair sur ce qu'elle est vraiment.
On ne comprend ni pourquoi ni comment elle existe.
Pour certains la conscience c'est juste une illusion
et pour d'autres il s'agit carrément
du plus grand mystère de l'univers.
Pour expliquer l'existence de cette conscience
subjective, on peut faire appel à la science,
mais on va voir que c'est aussi un problème
qui est largement philosophique
et qui nous renvoie à des questions sur la nature profonde
de ce que nous sommes et du monde qui nous entoure.
Pour vous en parler aujourd'hui, j'ai donc décidé
de faire équipe avec un philosophe, un vrai,
j'ai nommé Thibault de la chaîne monsieur Phi.
Alors Thibault, qui es-tu
et qu'est-ce qu'on trouve sur ta chaîne ?
Bonjour David et merci pour l'invitation.
Je suis prof de philo et logicien et sur ma chaîne,
on aborde tous les champs de la philosophie.
Et contrairement à l'idée qu'on s'en fait parfois, je pense
que la philosophie est plutôt proche des sciences
en ceci qu'elle partage les mêmes ambitions
de connaissance et de compréhension du monde
par des moyens rationnels.
Et en particulier sur un sujet comme la conscience,
il me semble très bénéfique
de faire travailler ensemble les sciences et la philosophie.
Ok, mais avant qu'on attaque rassure-moi,
t'as bien une conscience toi ?
Alors, laisse moi vérifier...  [bruit numérique]
Ouais c'est bon, j'ai une conscience.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Notre conscience, notre vie mentale intérieure,
est riche de tout un tas de phénomènes :
des perceptions sensorielles comme par exemple
des sons, des odeurs ou des couleurs;
mais aussi des sensations intérieures
comme des douleurs ou des démangeaisons.
Dans notre flux de conscience on trouve aussi
des émotions comme la colère ou la joie
et des pensées plus ou moins complexes
qui ont toutes un ressenti particulier, spécifique.
Si par exemple là je pense à un plat de spaghettis,
ça ne provoque pas en moi la même expérience intérieure
que si je pense à une grosse araignée velue
ou à Jennifer Lawrence.
Tous ces phénomènes mentaux
qu'on expérimente en permanence
semblent en apparence très différents des phénomènes
physiques qui agitent le monde qui nous entoure.
Le monde physique ce sont des objets qui se déplacent,
des particules qui intéragissent,
des réactions chimiques qui se déroulent
et à première vue, on ne voit pas très bien
comment expliquer notre expérience consciente,
notre vie intérieure avec toute la richesse qu'elle contient,
juste avec des particules et
des réactions chimiques qui s'enchaînent.
Notre conscience et le monde physique
semblent deux choses totalement différentes.
Mais est-ce qu'on peut aller au delà des apparences ?
Qu'est-ce qui nous fait dire que
les phénomènes mentaux seraient à part ?
Et bien, suppose que je te dise
que j'ai une douleur très vive au bras.
Qu'est-ce que tu ferais pour étudier ce phénomène ?
Et bien, j'examinerais ton bras pour voir
s'il y a des bleus ou des blessures.
Peut-être que je te ferais passer une radio
pour voir s'il n'est pas cassé.
Mais ce que tu verrais sur mon bras ou sur la radio,
est-ce que ce serait vraiment ma douleur ?
Tu verras peut-être une fracture et tu supposeras
que cette fracture cause ma douleur,
mais la fracture est un phénomène physique
et elle est en soi tout à fait distincte de ma douleur,
qui est un phénomène mental.
Savoir s'il y a une fracture, cela n'a rien d'immédiat
et surtout l'erreur est possible.
Même si je voyais mon bras tordu et sanglant, cela
pourrait être du maquillage, ou une illusion d'optique,
ou bien mes os pourraient être en faits en caoutchouc.
Ce n'est pas absolument impossible,
ce serait juste surprenant.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'il y a un sens
à distinguer entre croire avoir une fracture
et avoir réellement une fracture,
entre l'apparence et la réalité de la fracture.
Maintenant, suppose que tu m'as fait passer
tous les tests médicaux possibles
et que tu n'as vu aucune fracture, ni aucune anomalie
à quelque niveau que ce soit.
Pourrais-tu finir par me dire: "Ecoute, je pense
que tu fais erreur sur ta douleur,
on a bien regardé ton bras, il n'a rien, donc tu crois
avoir mal, mais en fait tu n'as pas mal."
Non, quand on a mal, on a mal,
on le sait tout de suite, on ne peut pas
se tromper sur le fait qu'on a mal.
En effet, autrement dit, il n'y a pas de sens à distinguer
entre l'apparence de la douleur et sa réalité,
l'apparence de la douleur est la douleur,
croire avoir mal, c'est avoir mal
et en cela, c'est un état très différent
d'un état physique comme une fracture.
La connaissance d'un état physique n'est jamais
immédiate et elle reste toujours faillible,
tandis qu'il y a quelque chose d'immédiat et d’infaillible
dans la connaissance que j'ai de mes propres états mentaux.
Ce qui est paradoxal, c'est que si je suis certain,
moi, de ressentir une douleur,
en fait je suis le seul à pouvoir le savoir avec certitude,
c'est un truc totalement personnel,
alors qu'un événement physique, comme le fait
qu'il y ait une fracture, ça on peut le savoir tous les deux
en regardant par exemple la radio ou bien mon bras.
C'est vrai, nous vivons tous dans le même monde
physique, mais la conscience que nous en avons
est une expérience absolument individuelle et incommunicable.
Cette connaissance immédiate et infaillible
que j'ai de mes propres états mentaux
est condamnée à rester privée.
J'aurais beau hurler de douleur en te montrant
mon bras tordu, ça ne te fera pas connaître ma douleur.
Tu pourrais essayer de l'imaginer, tu pourrais aller
jusqu'à te casser toi-même le bras par curiosité.
C'est un peu extrême là, quand même.
Mais surtout c'est inutile car ce ne sera jamais
que ta douleur que tu connaîtras et non la mienne.
Pour connaître vraiment ma douleur, il faudrait en quelque sorte en faire l'expérience à ma place,
il faudrait être moi.
En cela, les états mentaux sont subjectifs,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils se rattachent à un sujet, à un moi.
Cette différence entre un moi et le reste du monde
est centrale pour comprendre ce qu'est la conscience
et ce que sont les états mentaux.
Donc c'est clair, les phénomènes mentaux
ont un certain nombre de propriétés
qui les distinguent singulièrement
des phénomènes physiques,
d'ailleurs ça se voit bien à la manière dont on les décrit.
Les phénomènes mentaux sont subjectifs, privés
et du coup on les décrit en utilisant
la première personne, "je ressens ceci",
alors que les phénomènes physiques,
c'est tout le contraire,
ils sont objectifs, publics, tout le monde peut les observer
et on les décrit en utilisant la troisième personne,
"il se passe cela".
Ça pourrait ne pas poser de problème particulier
d'avoir d'un côté des phénomènes physiques
et de l'autre des phénomènes mentaux
qui seraient très différents,
mais ce qui est étrange, c'est que manifestement
ce ne sont pas deux mondes qui s'ignorent.
Les phénomènes mentaux semblent intimement liés
à certains phénomènes physiques.
Par exemple, on a tous cette idée intuitive que
notre conscience serait localisée dans notre cerveau
et même si on n'a jamais vu ou détecté
directement la conscience
et qu'on ne voit pas très bien d'ailleurs
comment elle pourrait sortir
de ce tas de matière flasque et humide qu'on a dans la tête,
on voit bien qu'un certain nombre de nos états
de conscience sont corrélés à des états cérébraux.
Déjà, première chose, on est conscient
quand notre cerveau est en état d'éveil,
ce qui est un truc qu'on peut caractériser
de façon physique, objective.
On n'est jamais conscient quand notre cerveau
est en état de sommeil profond
donc ça montre bien qu'il y a un lien
entre la conscience et le substrat cérébral
et puis on sait que la conscience et le cerveau
ont de multiples interactions réciproques.
Si je prends de l'aspirine par exemple,
ça va calmer ma douleur,
si je bois de l'alcool, mon flux de conscience
va être légèrement perturbé
et donc le physique agit sur le mental.
Et le lien de cause à effet semble pouvoir
se produire aussi dans l'autre sens,
si je veux lever mon bras, si je décide de lever mon bras,
cette volonté me semble mentale et pourtant
à la fin mon bras se lève physiquement
et d'ailleurs grâce aux différentes techniques d'imagerie
cérébrale comme par exemple l'IRM fonctionnelle,
on sait de mieux en mieux faire le lien
entre certains états de conscience
et l'activation de zones de notre cerveau.
En résumé la situation est la suivante:
notre conscience, nos états mentaux, semblent avoir
des caractéristiques très différentes du monde physique
et pourtant ces états sont irrémédiablement corrélés
à des états cérébraux qui sont donc, eux, physiques.
Cette constatation forme ce que les philosophes
appellent le problème du corps et de l'esprit
et le premier à vraiment poser les bases d'une théorie
pour essayer de l'expliquer, ça a été Descartes.
Descartes a présenté un argument historiquement
très important dans ses Méditations Métaphysiques.
Son point de départ, c'est cette infaillibilité
du mental dont on a déjà parlé,
il n'y a pas d'erreur possible sur mes propres états mentaux
et encore moins sur le fait que j'ai des états mentaux,
c'est-à-dire que j'ai une pensée, j'ai un esprit.
Par contre, il n'est pas impossible que je me trompe
entièrement sur le monde physique,
tout ça pourrait n'être qu'une vaste illusion que
je me construis moi même, comme dans un rêve,
même si c'est très improbable.
Conclusion qu'en tire Descartes, puisqu'il est possible
de douter de l'un mais absolument pas de l'autre,
c'est donc que le physique et le mental,
le corps et l'âme, ce sont deux choses distinctes.
C'est cette thèse de distinction de l'âme et du corps
qu'on appelle dualisme cartésien.
Dit comme ça, le dualisme cartésien,
ça me semble assez naturel, non ?
Je pense que si on interroge les gens dans la rue, spontanément,
la plupart seront d'accord pour dire
que le monde physique existe,
mais qu'ils ont aussi une âme, un esprit,
un truc en plus qui leur permet d'agir sur leur corps
et qui, avec un peu de chance,
va même survivre à leur mort physique,
d'ailleurs, on voit bien que toutes les grandes religions
sont plus ou moins implicitement dualistes.
Donc le dualisme à la Descartes, ça a l'air d'être une
explication plutôt satisfaisante au problème de la conscience,
sauf qu'en fait, elle n'est pas très populaire
chez les gens qui ont un peu réfléchi au problème,
qu'il s'agisse des scientifiques ou des philosophes.
Et oui, car si le dualisme explique bien
les spécificités du mental par rapport au physique,
par contre, il peine à rendre compte
des interactions entre mental et physique.
Comme tu l'as déjà dit, l'esprit semble
agir sur le corps et réciproquement,
mais comment l'expliquer dans un cadre dualiste ?
Pour Descartes, le point d'interaction entre l'âme
et le corps était une petite partie du cerveau,
la glande pinéale.
Pourquoi là, et bien parce que c'était en plein milieu
du cerveau qu'on ne savait pas à quoi ça servait.
Alors maintenant, on sait à quoi elle sert, il s'agit d'une
glande endocrine, donc qui sert à la sécrétion hormonale
et qui produit notamment de la mélatonine
qui est impliquée dans les rythmes biologiques,
comme par exemple l'alternance de la veille et du sommeil.
Donc Descartes se plantait sur la glande pinéale.
Mais de toute façon, où que vous logiez l'âme,
le même problème se pose.
Si les interactions entre l'âme et le corps
sont des interactions causales,
cela voudrait dire que lorsque ma volonté
fait se lever mon bras,
cet événement physique n'a pas été initiée
par une cause physique.
Ce serait donc littéralement surnaturel, arriver à bouger
son bras par la pensée serait de l'ordre du miracle.
Et par conséquent, aujourd'hui, la plupart des philosophes de l'esprit rejettent le dualisme
et lui préfèrent une autre thèse qu'on appelle
le physicalisme ou parfois le matérialisme.
La définition du physicalisme consiste à affirmer
qu'il n'existe rien d'autre que le monde physique,
tout n'est que matière, particules,
mais il n'existe pas de substance supplémentaire
telle que l'âme, l'esprit ou je ne sais quoi d'autre.
Cette thèse du physicalisme
peut paraître aussi assez naturelle,
d'ailleurs elle est complètement en accord avec la
manière dont on fait traditionnellement de la science.
En physique ou en chimie, l’âme ou l'esprit
ne rentre pas dans les équations,
ils ne font pas partie des choses qu'on prend en compte
pour essayer d'expliquer le déroulement des phénomènes.
Mais si on accepte cette thèse du physicalisme,
il va falloir expliquer comment la conscience peut exister,
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a des états mentaux, une vie
intérieure subjective alors qu'on est juste un tas de matière
et que d'autres tas de matière
comme les cailloux, à priori, n'en ont pas.
Une première variante du physicalisme
pour essayer de répondre à cette question,
c'est la théorie de l'identité esprit / cerveau.
C'est une théorie radicale qui dit que
l'esprit n'est rien d'autre que le cerveau
et que tout phénomène qu'on qualifie de mental
est en fait simplement un phénomène cérébral
et donc physique.
On peut prendre une analogie avec l'existence de la vie.
Pendant longtemps, on a pensé que
la vie était quelque chose de particulier,
de fondamentalement différent de la matière inerte.
Certains ont même imaginé qu'il puisse
y avoir une sorte de fluide vital
qui distinguerait les créatures vivantes des corps inanimés
et c'était justement le mot âme, plus précisément
psyché en grec et anima en latin,
qu'on utilisait pour désigner ce principe
qui anime les êtres vivants.
Le vivant c'est l'animé, c'est-à-dire ce qui est doué
d'une âme, ainsi distingué de l'inerte.
Oui, l’âme a d'abord été une notion biologique
qui ne renvoyait pas spécialement à la pensée.
On attribuait par exemple aux végétaux une âme,
une âme végétative qui les fait croître
et sans pour autant leur attribuer une pensée.
Mais bon, on sait aujourd'hui que la vie
n'a rien de fondamentalement mystérieux,
c'est juste de la chimie très sophistiquée.
Un organisme vivant n'est rien de plus qu'un tas
de molécules très complexes qui interagissent
et même si les propriétés des êtres vivants
ont l'air très différentes de celles des cailloux,
elles se réduisent en définitive
à des propriétés physiques et chimiques.
En somme, pas besoin d’âme pour expliquer le vivant.
Un organisme, c'est juste une machine physico-chimique
très complexe et très bien réglée.
L'un des premiers défenseurs de cette idée
c'était justement Descartes,
c'est le sens de sa fameuse thèse des animaux-machines
et c'est donc seulement à la suite de Descartes que le mot âme
va se mettre à renvoyer uniquement à l'esprit,
l'âme qui pense et non plus l'âme qui anime.
Pour les tenants de l'identité esprit / cerveau,
l'origine de la conscience serait en quelque sorte
de la même nature mais un niveau au dessus.
La conscience ne serait rien de plus
que la résultante de phénomènes biologiques
dont on n'a pas encore élucidé tous les ressorts,
mais sans qu'il y ait besoin
de faire intervenir quoi que ce soit d'autre.
Mais cette thèse comporte malgré tout quelques difficultés.
Si on imagine par exemple que la sensation de douleur
au dos corresponde à un certain état cérébral,
ça paraît assez peu crédible que deux personnes
qui aient toutes les deux mal au dos
soient exactement dans le même état cérébral
et si la conscience est une résultante
de la biologie telle qu'on la connaît,
ça voudrait dire que des formes de vie alternatives, par exemple
extraterrestres, ne pourraient pas avoir de conscience ?
On sent bien que cette vision de la conscience comme
réductible simplement à des phénomènes biologiques
est assez limitative.
De même qu'on arrive à imaginer
que des formes de vie puissent exister
sans faire appel exactement au mêmes substrats
chimiques que nous, par exemple l'ADN ou les protéines,
on devrait pouvoir imaginer des formes de conscience associées
et c'est ce qui a poussé les philosophes à développer
une variante de l'approche physicaliste de l'esprit.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Alors Thibault, cette variante du physicalisme.
Pour l'expliquer je vais faire un petit détour.
Cette machine à une propriété très intéressante,
quand tu lui donnes des nombres entiers en entrée,
il en ressort la somme de ces nombres
Oui, c'est juste un additionneur.
Une machine qui additionne, c'est incroyable !
Et on pourrait se demander, mais qu'est-ce que l'addition ?
Est-ce qu'il y a une âme additionnante dans cette machine ?
Mais bien sûr que non, c'est juste un processus
mécanique, physique et un système de crosse.
Mais je suppose que tu ne peux pas dire que l'addition
c'est précisément ce processus physique à base de crosses,
sans quoi ça voudrait dire que les calculatrices
modernes qui ne fonctionnent pas avec des crosses
et bien en fait, elles ne sont pas capables d'additionner.
Mais non, pour avoir une addition, il faut prendre des nombres
en entrée puis filer un nombre en sortie qui soit la somme.
Mais peu importe la machine, qu'elle soit
mécanique, électronique, on s'en fout,
en fait, il faut juste qu'elle réalise la bonne fonction.
Exactement, l'addition est une fonction
qui peut être réalisée de toutes sortes de façons.
On peut même construire un additionneur
dans le démineur de Windows, pourquoi pas.
Et ce qui est vrai d'une fonction toute simple comme l'addition
peut être tenu pour vrai plus généralement de toute fonction,
c'est ce qu'on appelle la thèse de la réalisabilité multiple.
Toute fonction, en gros, tout mécanisme
qui transforme des entrées en sorties
peut être implémenté de diverses façons
dans des systèmes de natures très différentes.
Maintenant, passons des machines qui additionnent
aux machines qui pensent.
Si l'on est physicaliste,
on doit croire que la pensée est le fruit d'un processus
physique qui se produit dans l'organisme,
de la même façon que l'addition est le fruit d'un processus
physique qui se produit dans la calculatrice.
Or on a vu que l'addition ne réside pas dans le processus
physique particulier qui a lieu dans la machine,
mais dans la fonction que celui-ci réalise
et la thèse qu'on peut défendre alors,
c'est qu'il en est de même pour la pensée.
La pensée n'est pas le processus biologique
particulier qui se déroule dans notre cerveau,
mais c'est la fonction que réalise ce processus.
C'est cette thèse qu'on appelle
en philosophie de l'esprit, le fonctionnalisme.
La pensée est la fonction réalisée biologiquement
dans notre organisme
qui transforme, en gros, des entrées sensorielles
en comportements.
En fait pour le fonctionnalisme,
on a une conscience parce qu'on est une machine
à traiter l'information suffisamment sophistiquée.
Notre système nerveux prend en entrée nos perceptions
et il donne en sortie nos actions physiques,
nos gestes, nos paroles.
En somme, ma pensée est bien liée
à des mécanismes biologiques,
mais l'erreur des partisans de l'identité esprit / cerveau
était de croire qu'elle était essentiellement
liée à ces mécanismes
de la même façon que l'addition serait essentiellement
liée au mécanisme de crosses de l'addiator.
Ma pensée est plutôt une fonction réalisée
en l'occurrence dans la biologie,
mais qui pourrait tout à fait l'être
dans d'autres types de systèmes,
par exemple dans une biologie extraterrestre très différente.
Ou même simplement dans un ordinateur.
D'après le fonctionnalisme, si j'ai un programme
informatique qui implémente la même fonction,
les mêmes relations entre les entrées
et les sorties qu'un cerveau humain,
ce programme informatique aura une conscience.
Et bien oui, le fonctionnaliste
aura toutes les raisons de le croire
et d'ailleurs, peut-être que comparé à ces intelligences artificielles,
notre réalisation biologique de la pensée
aura quelque chose d'aussi rudimentaire
que la réalisation mécanique de l'addition dans l'addiator.
Ça veut dire qu'il faudra peut-être un jour
considérer certains programmes informatiques
comme des êtres conscients à part entière
et qu'on risquera en débranchant son ordinateur
de tuer une intelligence artificielle ?
Est-ce qu'il faudra interdire la cruauté envers les IA de la même
manière qu'on condamne la cruauté envers les animaux.
Une autre implication perturbante de l'approche fonctionnaliste,
c'est qu'il n'existe aucune différence entre
un phénomène mental et sa simulation informatique
et donc on pourrait très bien n'être nous mêmes
que des simulations informatiques.
Une conséquence au moins aussi étrange du fonctionnalisme
tient à la possibilité de réaliser la fonction
du cerveau à une échelle macroscopique.
Nous avons 100 milliards de neurones figurez-vous !
Maintenant, imaginez qu'on réunisse
100 milliards d'êtres humains,
ça peut sembler énorme mais en fait en mettant juste
un être humain par mètre carré, ça tiendrait en Corée du Sud
et supposez qu'on fasse agir ces 100 milliards d'êtres humains
les uns avec les autres de la même façon que des neurones.
Par exemple, chacun serait muni d'un appareil qui lui
permet de recevoir un signal et d'en émettre à d'autres,
de la même façon que des neurones
peuvent être activés par d'autres neurones
et transmettre cette activation à d'autres.
Ce système formé de 100 milliards d'êtres humains
réaliserait, à une autre échelle, exactement
la même fonction que mon cerveau maintenant,
mais dira-t-on que ce système a une pensée,
qu'il a une véritable conscience
semblable, voire identique à ma conscience.
Et aussi, comme il est possible
de simuler un transistor électrique
avec juste de l'eau et puis un système
de vannes, de pompes et de bassines,
on pourrait imaginer un système hydraulique gigantesque
qui reproduirait le fonctionnement
d'un ordinateur simulant une conscience
et du coup, un énorme ensemble de bassines
et de pompes serait conscient, comme toi.
Et bien, un fonctionnaliste devrait répondre oui,
qu'importe la machine pourvu qu'on ait la fonction.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Aujourd'hui le fonctionnalisme a plutôt
la côte chez les philosophes de l'esprit
et pourtant, pour certains, cette approche échoue à prendre
en compte quelques aspects fondamentaux de la conscience.
Faisons l'expérience de pensée suivante.
Imaginez que dans ma tête, le spectre des couleurs
soit inversé par rapport au vôtre,
c'est-à-dire que, quand dans votre tête vous voyez ça,
et bien moi je vois ça,
depuis toujours.
Alors évidemment, quand on discute
on est d'accord sur les mots,
on affirme tous les deux que les tomates
sont rouges et que les salades sont vertes,
mais du coup, moi ce que j'appelle rouge,
c'est cette sensation là
et vert, cette sensation là.
Ça pourrait très bien que le cas, non ?
Comment on ferait pour s'en rendre compte ?
Même en sachant tout de la biologie de la perception
des couleurs, je ne pourrais pas savoir une telle chose.
Je sais l'effet que ça me fait de voir du rouge,
mais je ne peux pas savoir l'effet que ça te fait à toi.
Mais à priori, comme on est quand même très semblables
biologiquement, je pourrais supposer que c'est similaire.
Les choses deviennent plus piquantes lorsqu'on
considère une espèce biologique très différente.
Le philosophe Thomas Nagel, dans un article fameux,
prenait l'exemple de la chauve-souris.
Les chauves-souris se repèrent par écholocation,
c'est-à-dire qu'elles ont une sorte de sonar biologique
qui leur permet de se représenter l'espace autour d'elles.
Là pour le coup, on sait très bien
ce qu'il se passe physiquement,
l'écholocalisation des chauves-souris utilise des ultrasons
dont on comprend parfaitement la propagation,
vu de l'extérieur, il n'y a aucun problème.
Mais comprendre le fonctionnement de cet organe
nous permet-il vraiment de comprendre
qu'est-ce que ça fait de percevoir l'espace à travers lui,
quelle expérience du monde cet organe
donne-t-il aux chauves-souris.
Je ne peux m'imaginer des expériences conscientes que
par analogie avec mes propres expériences conscientes,
or je n'ai pas de sonar et je n'ai absolument rien qui y ressemble.
Il y aurait dans la connaissance du monde qu'a la
chauve-souris quelque chose qui m'échappe absolument,
l'effet que ça fait d'être une chauve-souris.
Je ne sais pas et ne peux pas savoir l'effet
que ça fait d'être une chauve-souris.
Cet effet que ça fait absolument subjectif,
incommunicable, privé,
irréductible à la connaissance du monde physique et qui
semble pourtant constituer une certaine forme de connaissance,
les philosophes le désignent aujourd'hui par le mot qualia.
Et la grande question est de savoir si les qualia ont une réalité
et c'est important, car admettre leur réalité
c'est remettre un pied dans le dualisme.
Pour montrer que les qualia sont réels
et représentent bien quelque chose
en plus de la réalité physique objectivement descriptible,
le philosophe Frank Jackson a proposé
l'expérience de pensée suivante,
connue sous le nom de "chambre de Marie".
Imaginons Marie, une savante extrêmement intelligente,
mais qu'on a enfermée toute sa vie dans une pièce
dans laquelle il n'y a que du noir et du blanc
ou bien on lui a mis des lunettes
qui convertissent tout en noir et blanc.
Marie est excellente en physique,
en neurobiologie, tout ce que vous voulez
et elle a accès à toutes les informations possibles
et imaginables sur la lumière, la propagation,
la manière dont elle est captée par l’œil,
analysée par le cerveau, etc...
Imaginons que Marie arrive à comprendre
tout ce qu'il est possible de comprendre
sur la perception des couleurs,
sur les états cérébraux impliqués,
jusque dans le détail de l'activation du moindre neurone,
sauf qu'elle vit dans un monde en noir et blanc.
Si un jour on décide finalement de sortir Marie de sa pièce
en noir et blanc et de lui montrer une rose rouge,
quelle va être sa réaction ?
Intuitivement, on se dit que ça va lui faire un choc,
qu'elle va faire une découverte,
la découverte de la sensation de rouge, du qualia rouge.
Elle va vraiment apprendre quelque chose
de nouveau en voyant cette rose rouge.
Même si elle avait pu anticiper, calculer complètement l'état
cérébral dans lequel elle se trouve en voyant cette rose rouge,
elle va vraiment apprendre quelque chose de nouveau.
Mais dans ce cas-là, ça signifie que même
en connaissant dans les moindres détails
tout ce qu'il y a à savoir des phénomènes physiques, biologiques,
cérébraux impliqués dans la perception des couleurs,
elle ne savait pas tout ce qu'il y a
à savoir sur la sensation de couleur.
Et pour Frank Jackson, cet argument
tend à montrer que notre conscience
et notamment l'existence des qualia,
ne peut pas complètement se réduire à des
phénomènes purement physiques et matériels
Si l'expérience de pensée vous paraît
un peu tirée par les cheveux,
en fait il n'y a pas besoin du tout
d'une pièce en noir et blanc pour la faire,
on la vit presque quotidiennement avec les odeurs.
Quand vous sentez une nouvelle odeur
que vous n'aviez jamais expérimentée auparavant,
on aurait bien pu tout vous expliquer sur les molécules,
les récepteurs olfactifs impliqués,
les zones cérébrales activées,
ça ne vous aurait pas aidé à anticiper
le ressenti subjectif de cette odeur.
Dernière petite expérience de pensée pour la route,
peux-tu imaginer la chose suivante ?
Une copie matérielle de toi parfaite,
un jumeau donc, qui aurait exactement
la même constitution matérielle que toi,
mais dénué de toute expérience consciente, dénué de qualia.
Il perçoit et réagit à son environnement
exactement comme toi,
mais chez lui ça n'est accompagné
d'aucune forme de conscience.
C'est ce qu'on appelle, sans rire, un zombie philosophique.
Du coup on parle beaucoup de zombies
en philosophie de l'esprit.
Tout à l'inverse des zombies de films de zombies
qui ont un comportement assez caractéristique,
les zombies philosophiques ne font rien de spécial.
Ton jumeau zombie aurait exactement
le même comportement que toi,
ainsi par exemple, si en respirant une certaine odeur
tu dis "hum, quelle odeur délicieuse",
ton jumeau zombie mis dans les mêmes conditions
aurait le même comportement,
dirait les mêmes mots, sur le même ton.
Mais la différence, c'est que chez toi ce sera
accompagné de l'expérience consciente de l'odeur,
tandis que chez lui, non, c'est un zombie.
Non, moi je sais bien que je ne suis pas un zombie,
mais ça se trouve, toi tu es un zombie
ou bien ma femme est un zombie...
En effet, et même si elle te disait avec conviction
qu'elle n'en est pas un, tu devrais te méfier,
c'est exactement ce que dirait un zombie.
Mais ne plongeons pas trop vite dans la paranoïa,
la question est surtout de savoir, est-ce que
cette hypothèse a seulement du sens ?
Beaucoup de philosophes tendent à penser
que cette notion de zombie est en fait absurde.
Traiter l'information, avoir exactement le même
comportement qu'un être conscient, c'est être conscient
et ici, il est tout aussi difficile d'argumenter
dans un sens que dans l'autre.
On touche là vraiment à ce qu'on appelle,
le problème difficile de la conscience.
Ce que mettent en lumière toutes ces réflexions
sur les qualia, qu'on adhère ou non à leur réalité,
c'est qu'il y a et qu'il y aura toujours un gouffre
entre l'explication du fonctionnement
de quelque système physique que ce soit
et l'idée que ce système physique
produit une expérience consciente
et ce gouffre n'est pas du même type que celui qui nous sépare
d'une pleine compréhension
du fonctionnement du cerveau, par exemple.
Ce gouffre-ci tient seulement
à la complexité biologique de l'objet étudié
tandis que le gouffre explicatif qui nous sépare de
la compréhension de la conscience semble plus radical.
En somme la question, "d'où vient ma conscience ?"
ressemble moins à une question technique,
comme comment fonctionne mon cerveau, qu'à une
question fondamentale, comme d'où vient la réalité,
c'est-à-dire une question fascinante, vertigineuse
et qu'on ne peut pas s'empêcher de se poser,
mais à laquelle on devine qu'absolument
aucune réponse ne peut être satisfaisante.
Evidemment, ne vous attendez pas à une conclusion
ferme et définitive sur ces questions,
même si, on l'a dit, aujourd'hui
la plupart des philosophes de l'esprit
se reconnaissent dans le physicalisme fonctionnaliste.
Et toi d'ailleurs Thibault ?
Je suis plutôt fonctionnaliste j'avoue,
même si des expériences de pensée
comme celle de la foule de 100 milliards d'êtres
humains qui réalisent la fonction de mon cerveau
me mettent mal à l'aise,
mais je dirais que c'est justement dans cet inconfort que
réside une bonne part de la valeur de toutes ces réflexions.
Si l'actualité de ces débats vous intéresse, les deux principaux camps qui s'affrontent aux yeux du grand public
sont représentés par David Chalmers et Daniel Dennett.
Dennett est un physicaliste pur et dur
qui pense que la conscience va finir par nous apparaître
comme un simple phénomène fonctionnel, biologique,
que les qualia sont juste une illusion
et qu'il n'y a pas de problème difficile.
De l'autre côté, on a David Chalmers le créateur
et ardent défenseur de l'argument des zombies,
celui qui a popularisé le terme de
"problème difficile de la conscience"
et qui lui, est fermement convaincu que
le physicalisme rate quelque chose d'essentiel
et comme Chalmers ne peut pas décemment
ressusciter le dualisme cartésien,
il cherche une solution radicale au problème
de la conscience, par exemple avec le panpsychisme.
Il s'agit d'une thèse qui postule que tout élément de
matière possède une forme élémentaire de conscience
et que leur association en structures complexes finit par
produire des êtres conscients, complexes, comme nous.
En somme, on a d'un côté un Père Noël
selon qui nous sommes tous des zombies
et de l'autre un surfeur selon qui
chaque grain de sable a une conscience.
Et vous pensez que la philosophie contemporaine est ennuyeuse ?
Petit complément pour conclure,
si vous êtes un ou une habitué(e) de la chaîne,
vous êtes peut être frustré(e) qu'on ait si peu parlé de science,
d'autant que le problème de la conscience est justement
fréquemment abordé sous l'angle des neurosciences.
La raison, je l'évoquée au tout début de la vidéo,
c'est que j'avais surtout envie de parler de cette question
de la conscience phénoménale, ce problème difficile
qui semble justement échapper
à l'analyse scientifique classique.
Si vous voulez prolonger ces questions, je vous
recommande d'aller voir la dernière vidéo de Monsieur Phi
qui parle justement de ces
différentes facettes de la conscience,
la conscience phénoménale dont on a parlé aujourd'hui
et la conscience d'accès qui est celle dont parlent
plus traditionnellement les neurosciences
et Thibault nous parle d'un phénomène assez étonnant.
Je vais essayer de montrer qu'on peut voir
avec son cerveau sans voir avec sa conscience.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo.
Si vous avez aimé, surtout courez
vous abonner à la chaîne de Monsieur Phi,
il ne parle pas que de philosophie de l'esprit
et ce qu'il fait c'est vraiment super.
vous pouvez aussi aller le soutenir
sur tipeee donc n'hésitez pas.
Si vous voulez les actus de la chaîne de mon côté
ça se passe sur Facebook et sur Twitter
et on se retrouve très bientôt pour des nouvelles vidéos.
...